Hallöchen ihr Lieben! Heute gibt's eine leckere Linsensuppe.
Es ist ja so, dass man nachdem man stundenlang - teilweise bis zu 16h! - gefastet hat,
dass man wirklich den Magen erstmal auf festes Essen vorbereiten muss.
Und daher trinkt man zum Fastenbrechen, also zum Iftar eine Suppe.
Und ich mache heute die syrische Linsensuppe.
Ihr kennt die türkische Linsensuppe von mir und die ist glaube ich auch ultra, ultra bekannt!
Aber die syrische Linsensuppe hat weniger Zutaten,
schmeckt auch super lecker aber nochmal ganz anders als die türkische,
also als Mercimek Çorbası.
[Kiki] Auf Arabisch heißt diese Suppe dann..?
[Hamza] Adas!
[Hamza] Schorbat Adas!
[Kiki] Schorbat Adas. Adas?
[Kiki] Okay, ich höre mich bestimmt richtig...
[Hamza] So wie Adidas!
Okay, also los geht's!
Die Zubereitung kommt jetzt und die Zutaten stehen wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Ich habe jetzt schon Zwiebeln grob geschnitten.
Wir pürieren das gleich eh, daher müsst ihr euch da nicht so viel Mühe geben.
Da nehme ich jetzt noch meine Knoblauchzehen und werde sie auch ganz grob klein schneiden,
gebe dann meinen Olivenöl in meinen Topf und dünste das schonmal für ca. 1-2min an.
So, ihr könntet jetzt entweder gemahlenen Kurkuma dazugeben
oder frischen wenn ihr den grad da habt.
Und was auf jeden Fall jetzt schon mit dazukommt, ist gemahlener Kreuzkümmel, der ist super wichtig.
Der ganze Vorgang mit dem Dünsten dauert ungefähr 2-3min
und danach gebt ihr auch schon heißes Wasser mit dazu.
Das kocht jetzt gerade auf, jetzt brauchen wir rote Linsen.
Ihr seht's schon, ich hab die hier kurz unter kaltem Wasser ausgespült
und die gebe ich jetzt noch mit rein,
salze das Ganze, gebe den Deckel drauf und dann lasst ihr das 20min lang köcheln.
Ihr dürft aber auch gerne zwischendurch auf den Boden schauen, dass da nichts anpappt
und die Linsen sollten in der Zeit dann weich geworden sein.
Also hier wie gesagt mein Salz noch mit dazu
ich kümmere mich in der Zwischenzeit um unsere..
ich würde mal sagen Brotchips, aber das zeige ich euch gleich.
Übrigens habe ich das Rezept von Schwiegermama weil -
also Hamza ist jetzt zwar kein Syrer aber es ist total weit verbreitet,
dass generell in arabischen Haushalten man so rund um den nah-östlichen Bereich kocht.
Und sie hatte das mal gemacht und ich wusste schon es gibt an dem Tag Linsensuppe
und ich habe mich voll auf die türkische Suppe eingestellt und dann hab ich probiert und dachte mir so:
"Wow, was ist das denn? Das schmeckt ja nochmal ganz anders!"
Und dann habe ich sie nach dem Rezept gefragt. Was sie nicht macht, sind jetzt diese Brotchips
weil das fand ich ganz cool und das habe ich auch schonmal bei dem einen oder anderen Syrer gesehen
dass man dafür eben dieses arabische Fladenbrot nimmt und in kleine Quadrate schneidet
und das ist eben gut wenn das alt ist und das ist so perfekt gerade!
Weil ich hatte das noch übrig und es ist so schade, das wegzuschmeißen.
Daher einfach - was ihr auch machen könnt, ist das Ganze zu halbieren weil die sind ja doppellagig.
und dann schneidet ihr das fein, erhitzt etwas Frittieröl
und dann frittiert ihr das 30sek darin an und dann sind das so wie.. so wie Croutons!
[Hamza] Chips!
[Kiki] Chips!
Ich rede immer so schnell wenn ich aufgeregt bin!
Ich bin halt so aufgeregt, ich freue mich auf die Suppe! Ganz ehrlich, Suppe ist immer was Tolles!
So die Brotchips sind fertig und mein Herd hat auch gerade gepiept,
also die 20min sind um, die Linsen sind richtig schön weich.
Das Einzige, was ihr jetzt noch machen müsst, ist das Ganze zu - zü pürieren! Zu pürieren.
Und danach schmecken wir das noch mit Salz und Pfeffer ab
und serviert wird das Ganze dann mit Zitrone.
[Hamza] Waas? Ich dachte du fastest!
Ja okay, also wir haben das Video jetzt vorgedreht. Also Ramadan beginnt in einer Woche.
Ah, dann kannst du noch den Taste Test machen! Und später dann kannst du den Taste Test nicht mehr machen.
Oder du wartest dann bis zum - Nein, so lange kannst du nicht warten!
Mmh, wie bei Schwiegermama. Perfekt!
[Hamza] War's das?
[Kiki] Nein, das war's. Dein Taste Test wird ein bisschen länger ausfallen als meiner! *lacht*
So bevor ihr gleich den Taste Test von Hamza seht, wünsche ich euch schonmal ganz viel Spaß beim Nachkochen!
Ich werde euch in die Infobox auch 'ne Playlist mit weiteren Suppen verlinken
falls ihr dann noch mehr Inspiration braucht, z.B. Harira Suppe,
oder auch allgemein mal 'ne Brokkolisuppe, türkische Linsensuppe etc.
[Hamza] Spargelsuppe!
Genau, die fehlt nämlich noch auf meinem Kanal, Danke für den Druck!
[Hamza] Deswegen hab ich's ja gesagt!
Und ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch schöne Tage.
Schreibt mir gerne einen Kommentar wie euch das Rezept gefallen hat
und wenn ihr weitere Rezeptwünsche habt, immer hier unten in die Kommentare schreiben.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!
So, ich darf den Taste Test machen obwohl Ramadan gerade ist!
Ganz ehrlich Leute: Ihr müsst das nicht sehen!
Also wenn ihr gerade fastet, dann guckt euch das nicht an weil ich will's jetzt genießen.
Also mal gucken wie viele Taste Tests ich machen kann noch, die wir vordrehen!
[Kiki] Ich sag so 5-7 Stück!
[Hamza] Hoffe ich mal. Umso mehr, desto besser!
Also ich pack mal die Zitrone rein, ne?
[Kiki] Ja, Zitrone passt!
So! Und jetzt ob du's geschafft hast wie meine Mama die Suppe macht,
ob du auf den Geschmack kommst, das wär heftig!
Ja, du hast es geschafft! Kiki hat's geschafft.
[Kiki] Schmeckt gut?
[Hamza] M-hm!
[Kiki] Z.B. im Gegensatz zur türkischen Linsensuppe kein Paprikamark, keine Kartoffeln, keine Möhren..
[Hamza] Ich finde das kann man echt Linsensuppe nennen, also wirklich 100% Linsensuppe.
Weil das ist dann eher so eine Gemüsesuppe. Klar, Mercimek hin oder her
aber da schmeckst du wirklich die Linsen raus.
Bei dem Mercimek schmeckst du nicht wirklich die Linsen raus, da schmeckst du eher Paprika raus.
Aber natürlich ist das auch sehr lecker. Also ich will das jetzt nicht schlechtreden oder so, das schmeckt auch mega lecker!
Aber hier schmeckst du wirklich Linsen raus. Und das ist das Linsensuppe - das ist das Gericht finde ich.
Aber kann auch sein, dass ich durch meine arabische Zunge gerade eh alles toll finde
weil du das einfach geschafft hast wie meine Mama Zuhause zu machen, von daher...
Vielleicht ist da auch ein bisschen Liebe im Magen dabei, weiß ich nicht!
Liebe geht bekanntlich durch den Magen!
Das schmeckt wirklich mega gut Leute!
Wenn ihr die Leute - wenn ihr Besuch habt..
Vor allem die Portion war super! Ich glaube das war für 6 Portionen, oder?
[Kiki] Also wenn's wirklich eine Iftar Vorspeise sein soll, dann hat man auch nicht so viel wie du jetzt.
[Kiki] Dann reicht das für 6 Personen, ansonsten für 4 Personen als Hauptspeise.
[Kiki] Wenn wir über die Suppe schon so viel reden, was machen wir dann in den nächsten Videos wenn's richtig abgeht mit Hauptspeisen und Desserts?
Ich freu mich richtig drauf! Wooh!
[Kiki] *lacht*
Das wird richtig geil, das wird richtig cool! Leute, ihr könnt euch auf geile Rezepte freuen weil
macht das Zuhause nach, unbedingt nachmachen!
Und vor allem wenn ihr eine Schwiegermama habt, die aus dem arabischen Raum kommt
und ihr das serviert - und das ist wirklich nicht schwer! Das ist nicht schwer gewesen.
[Kiki] Das ist mega, mega einfach und schnell!
[Hamza] Ich mein das kann sogar ich machen!
Also wenn ich das kann, könnt ihr das schon lange! *lacht*
Dann müsst ihr's unbedingt nachmachen! Glaubt mir, eure Schwiegermutter
oder eure Bekannten oder sonst was, die werden richtig stolz auf euch sein!
[Hamza] Kiki, kennst du diesen Film Ratatouille?
[Kiki] Ja!
Kennst du das wo am Ende dieser Restaurant-Tester dann dieses Ratatouille isst?
Und dann hat er sich wieder zurück gefühlt wie seine Oma das früher gemacht hat?
Genau das ist dieser Moment!
[Kiki] Okay, schön gesagt!
So! Leute, Prost!
[Kiki] Prost an Ramadan! *lacht*
Peace and out! Und abonnieren und liken nicht vergessen!